so I have a game for you guys today we
are gonna play a round would you rather
so picking between the two things and
then telling me why you would choose one
or the other so first one would you
rather work with a director who gives
you too many notes or not enough both
are equally painful and I'd rather what
maybe Oh God maybe no I don't know I
have no idea
would you rather get to have as many
takes as you'd like or half the nail in
one I would rather have to nail in one
cuz that's like theater and I think when
you know that's the case you'd bring it
you bring the Thunder
she and she would you'd be good with
that some actors would not be good with
that they would mentally just kind of
combust under the pressure of it but I
think I think if you tell an actor yeah
listen
yeah there's no light yeah you have to
nail it they will bring it yeah I think
often times maybe were given to em too
much leeway yeah I think Oh we'll fix it
later so you don't bring everything you
yeah
maybe that's me Phil yeah like there's a
lot of great movie shot on film and I
with digital when you do have more takes
yeah it's important and why editing can
become so difficult because they can try
16 different things and improvisation
[ __ ] mess this movie we got a lovely
it was not just wine we got some
sometimes just two or three years
sometimes more we were improvising a lot
too to get into the mood and they were
just playing with that so I don't know
it depends on the director I think so
the follow-up to that one would you
rather work with an actor whose method
or someone who improvises too much never
too much so I prefer someone who has
stanislavski's method could it be both
too much maybe she says too much too
much sometimes it's really good it's not
no it's like you know just if I have a
method actor
the next one too much improvisation this
is too much and probably let's just keep
balancing it you know would you rather
go with your gut or have to screen test
something you're working on definitely
go with my gut good God
but but I do believe in screening for
smart people just to feel people
watching things I'd rather just go with
your gut but like it sucks to have
something come out and you realize you
made a giant mistake and you didn't rise
cuz you never showed anybody so did you
do that with this movie and what was the
what was probably the most helpful thing
I guess you learned from that process um
we started to scream i screen a lot on
this film because i wanted to see i knew
it was a challenging film where
difficult things happened and so i i
wanted to see how it played I didn't
change a lot after the screenings it it
kind of is very close to what the first
cut of it was ice cream constantly on my
television show because people are are
so invested for such a long period of
time that sometimes I bring in fans of
the show I make them sign NDA agreements
and I screen the controversial stuff
just to get a sense of like are our fans
gonna jump off a ledge in a good way or
bad alright we if we do it I mean we've
had we've had things that we've changed
because of it on the show particularly
not because we were changing what our
intent was but like the reaction was so
severe and distracting to something we
were doing you know that kind of twist
that people we were like oh this is
gonna go out of control and snowball in
a way that like will be distracting for
the stuff that man would you rather have
to fake sneeze or fake vomit in a scene
fake vomit fake sneeze well the question
is can you do a convincing fake sneeze
because I thought things hurt me that's
really good what was your question
alright you know that I think fake vomit
is a lot easier fake sneeze is really
hard there to do a convincing fake
sneeze is really hard it sneezes yeah
okay that's nice that's nice that's
pretty good what do you prefer is made
for vomiting yeah
vomiting really you prefer that oh yeah
but you just did a convincing fake
sneeze it seems just to make sure
oh what is easier Steve is easier
well I would go with the easy she's very
difficulties to to you young but really
because action and you try to find it
it's never it's never it's never good I
also have one or it's would you rather
have to wake up or fall asleep in a
scene because I feel like that is just
probably one of the most challenging but
like simple things to actually do in a
natural way I can't fall asleep any
moment yeah waking up in a scene is also
hard to do well it's so easy to spot it
movies like that person was not just
leaping good especially when they wake
up with a face full of makeup on yeah is
it dead giveaway yeah I do I often fall
asleep in scenes so it's helpful I fall
asleep like a cartoon character though
in real life like I'll be like hey maybe
ha don't my just God would you rather
have to eat or run in a scene well I'll
give a good story about that I was one
of these young actors I was doing
Chicago Hope I don't know how old I was
not young enough but not old yet and and
there was a scene where it said I had to
drink prune juice well I thought you
know prune juice you know I'm the real
thing I'm gonna do it like the way
Dustin did it I'm gonna do it too so
there was princess I drank the whole
glass of prune juice and then they said
we gotta do it again ok another glass of
prune juice before I knew what I drank
like 8 quarts of prune juice and it was
interesting for the next four days no I
I had an active you had to just knock
down two glasses of wine which were
prune juice and had to be retired the
rest of the day
yes so stay away from the prune juice is
all I have to say to young actors or old
actors or any actors anywhere or anyone
would you rather have to do a romance
scene with someone knowing that they
have bad breath or knowing that you have
bad breath yeah knowing that you have
liver actually that question is not a
cake because either if it's your or the
other one it's [ __ ] up what do you why
do you prefer nobody you know what I
mean
I prefer I prefer I to help at me having
the bad breath because then I can
you know and maybe you don't know it
Brad I'm gonna tell you go eat something
no brush your teeth or something but
it's [ __ ] up anyway